it was just before 10 o'clock in the
evening that the stabbing took place the
home of a rabbi had been serving as a
synagogue on the seventh night of the
Jewish festival of Hanukkah the attack
prompting a major response from
emergency services we live together we
never have that kind of incident before
it's outrageous I'm upset you know I
mean I hope they find whoever wants to
commit coming in this town to commit
this type of the crime to not come in
anymore it's not tolerate it happened in
the town of Mon C about an hour north of
New York City it is an area known for
its large population of ultra-orthodox
Jews there were dozens of people inside
the house at the time of the attack a
suspect has been arrested but he hasn't
been identified by police New York
Police Department's counterterrorism
Bureau said it was closely monitoring
the incident the state's attorney
general said she was deeply disturbed by
what had happened adding there was zero
tolerance for acts of hatred of any kind
it comes as police have reported a wave
of anti-semitic violence across the New
York area in the last two weeks police
have stepped up patrols in a number of
neighborhoods there is a nationwide
pattern in California in April a gunman
killed a female rabbi and wounded a
number of other people during a service
on the last day of Passover six months
earlier in the deadliest anti-semitic
attack in US history eleven worshippers
were killed at the Tree of Life
synagogue in Pittsburgh what's happening
now is officials say an alarming
situation and in another American
community the cost counted in victims of
yet more violence Greg Milam sky news